allez y
allez versailles sont répétés en boucle
cette semaine lors de ce stage de
football à versailles à quelques jours
de la demi finale historique face à nice
les jeunes du fc versailles 78 ne cesse
de parler des exploits de leurs aînés
dans cette coupe de france 2022 un
parcours qu'ils ont scruté avec
attention c'est une pensée pour un club
de n2 c'est bien est ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est extraordinaire surtout face à
toulouse le bit djoko est aussi le but
de diarra se bat contre bergerac liées
qui seront passés là quarts de finale
huitième de finale espère qu'ils vont
passer au concret ni sait qu'ils vont
gagner donc et du coup je vais supporter
leur cei pour qu'elle puisse gagner ce
jeu les ont croisés sur le terrain les
74 jeunes présents tentent d'imiter les
gestes des demi-finalistes de la coupe
de france des joueurs devenus en
quelques semaines leur idole pour moi
c'est une star mais surtout joe cole
marque beaucoup de buts il est beau
handball
en tous les cas dans tous les cas c'est
mon préféré de tous vers salle g que vu
de près vieira et l'entraîneur est alors
je leur ai fait un check et voilà
l'équipe première qu'il rêve de
rejoindre dans le futur en fait avec
tous les enfants les autres
enfin ça nous ça nous fait plaisir ça
nous donne du courage pour venir jusqu'à
ce niveau m'hand national de voir plus
loin encore tous nous l'ont assuré le
regarderont le match même si la plupart
seront sur leur lieu de vacances un
rendez vous qui me le rateraient pour
rien au monde
[Applaudissements]